today's episode of the y-files is
brought to you by established titles
everyone's heard of Area 51 the top
secret facility in the Nevada desert but
nobody really knows what happens there
we have only rumors one rumor is that
alien bodies have been recovered from
UFO crashes those aliens have been
autopsied and the subjects of medical
experiments for years but have you ever
heard of Dulce base Dolce is more secret
than Area 51 and more Sinister if Area
51 is the place where humans experiment
on Aliens Dulce is the place where
aliens experiment on us
foreign
Dulce is a town in New Mexico near the
Colorado border on the hickorya Apache
reservation though the town is small
with fewer than 3 000 people the area
has the largest number of UFO sightings
per capita in the world the stories of
strange lights and objects in the sky go
back as far as the first people to
inhabit the area thousands of years ago
newer stories claim there's an
underground base within the Archuleta
Mesa near Dulce although there's never
been hard evidence of this base there
are quite a few people who have come
forward over the years that indicate
something is happening in the area there
are witnesses who claim to have worked
on the construction of the base worked
at the base and some who've seen it from
the air there are even people who have
claimed to have seen the base from the
inside after being taken there against
their will in 1975 a rancher in Dulce
called the police in a panic one of his
cattle had been killed at first he
thought it was a predator but predators
don't do this officer Gabe Valdez
responded to the call he couldn't
believe what he found the cow was
drained of all its blood and had
undergone a procedure where many of its
organs were surgically removed and
around the cow's carcass were tracks in
the soil that looked like they came from
the feet of a tripod next to each of the
tracks the ground was scorched
indicating there was an aircraft that
could take off and land vertically in
the tracks there was a yellow oily
substance that couldn't be identified by
Any Lab it seemed as if the tripods
whatever they were followed the cow for
about 600 feet Valdez was able to see
where the cow had struggled before this
happened Valdez knew this was a little
outside of his Lane so he contacted Dr
Howard Burgess of Sandia National Labs
Dr Burgess arrived 72 hours later to
assist though three days had passed the
cow wasn't decomposing and predators and
scavengers wouldn't go near it and at
some point during those three days one
of the cow's ears was removed over the
following months 17 animals would be
killed this way all were missing their
lymph nodes all or missing multiple
organs and all taken surgically all the
animals were drained of blood and the
little blood that remained wouldn't clot
not even after several days soon
investigators started to become sick
seven people who visited the ranch
complained about headaches and nausea
this gave Dr Burgess the idea to test
radiation levels in the area and
radiation was twice what it should be
and during this time investigators
working at night saw orange lights
moving silently in the sky investigators
working during the day saw black
helicopters circling overhead Valdez
wondered if this was more than a local
phenomena he looked for cases of animal
mutilation in the surrounding areas and
over the course of a few years an
estimated 8 000 animal mutilations were
reported now I was able to find the
official FBI report on this which I'll
link below and despite everything I've
told you about the condition of these
animals the FBI said quote it was
consistent with predator action and
there is no federal interest in
continuing an investigation the only
Predator that can do this is the
Predator what predator is that well you
know
you know funny you bring that up where
was that Predator from
um another planet well no if it bleeds
we can kill it
[Music]
Paul Bennett was born in 1927 and when
World War II broke out he joined the
Coast Guard as a teenager he had a
master's degree in physics and was
pursuing his PhD when he opened an
electronics company in Albuquerque New
Mexico Paul benewitz's primary clients
were the Air Force in NASA he did so
much business with the air force that he
actually bought a home and established a
lab right next to Kirtland Air Force
Base and we have an entire episode that
covers him and how he was misled and
abused by the United States government
link below Kirtland Air Force Base is a
massive complex spanning over 80 square
miles over 20 000 people work on the
base Kirtland also happens to be the
largest storage facility for nuclear
weapons in the Western Hemisphere on the
grounds are the Manzano mountains and
under the monzanos are 80 underground
bunkers including a presidential
emergency shelter connecting the bunkers
are over 40 separate tunnels though
nobody knows for sure how many the
people who built the facility were not
allowed to tell anyone about what they
were working on Paul benowitz was a
gifted engineer and was interested in
UFOs from Paul's second floor balcony he
observed and filmed strange lights in
the sky he also recorded radio
Transmissions that seemed to be alien in
origin Paul occasionally worked for
several UFO groups including the aerial
phenomena research organization known as
apro and even though UFO research wasn't
yet mainstream apra was a respected
organization known for scientifically
grounded research in 1979 Paul attended
a conference in Albuquerque where he met
officer Gabe Valdez they traded stories
about cattle mutilations alien
abductions and UFO sightings that were
happening in the area Gabe Valdez and
Paul benowitz struck up a friendship
Valdez was basically the go-to cop for
any strange phenomenon in the area and
Paul was compiling more and more data
that aliens were real were here and were
very interested in Kirtland Air Force
Base in 1980 Valdez caught the Myrna
Hanson case and asked Paul benowitz for
help Myrna Hansen claimed to have had a
terrifying experience when she was
driving to her home in Eagles Nest New
Mexico both she and her son saw two UFOs
over a field they left the car running
and got out to take a closer look they
saw a cow grazing in the field get
lifted into one of the UFOs by being
polite the next thing she knew Myrna and
her son were back in the car the engine
off and hours had passed now what
happened during those hours she had
trouble remembering and what she did
remember she had trouble discussing so
Gabe and Paul brought in a psychology
Professor to place Myrna on her hypnosis
to see if she could access these
suppressed Memories the hypnosis session
began and based on what Myrna Hansen
remembered she had every reason to be
terrified
[Music]
thank you
Myrna Hansen remembered that as she was
driving and saw very bright lights in
the sky she and her son got out of the
car to see what they were the lights
were coming from a floating craft and
were affecting a herd of cattle one cow
seemed to be struggling and panicking as
it was levitated up into one of the
objects then she remembered that she was
abducted and given a thorough and very
violating physical examination and
though her abductors never spoke she
recalls hearing them in her mind they
said she was taken by accident but now
that she was here they had no choice but
to continue with the procedure she
described their appearance as what we
now call a gray alien she also reported
being taken to an underground base and
there she saw body parts floating in
Vats of bubbling liquid and she
remembered a terrible smell the alien
abduction stories are unfortunately
fairly common now but In 1980 this was
very unusual then Myrna remembered
something really disturbing something
that could be confirmed she she said a
device was surgically implanted into her
body and she believed this was so the
aliens could track her and control her
mind now this could be checked Myrna was
taken to the nearby Lovelace Medical
Center and X-rayed at the base of her
skull right where she said it would be
was the implant Myrna also had a very
faint scar on the back of her neck now
to be fair the doctors thought it was a
natural growth though they didn't know
what kind the doctors might not have
been convinced but Myrna Hansen gave
Valdez and Paul benowitz were there was
an alien presence focused on the
Kirtland Air Force Base and on the town
of Dulce not far away now remember Paul
benowitz was reporting everything he saw
to the Air Force Richard Doty an agent
working for the Air Force office of
special investigation or OSI was
assigned to Paul's case Dodie and Paul
spent so much time together that they
became personal friends Paul showed
Richard Dodie sketches that Myrna Hansen
made of what she saw while she was
abducted she Drew hallways elevators
rooms and Laboratories then don't
confirmed that her drawings match the
Manzano weapon storage complex which was
an underground facility and over the
next 20 years more and more information
would emerge that confirmed not only are
aliens on Earth but they're also working
with the United States government but
when did this partnership begin and why
would the government be working with
aliens and for what goal well in 1995 we
would get our answer when Phil Schneider
an engineer who helped build Dulce base
blew the whistle and it's darker than
you could possibly imagine
[Music]
foreign
the Pentagon budget was 750 billion
dollars and since 1996 the American
Military has received 8.5 trillion in
taxpayer dollars and never has had to
account for any of it in 2016 an
investigation discovered that the
Pentagon was covering up 125 billion in
so-called wasted dollars that if the
military budget comes up short in a
given year whatever number that is is
just written in it's called a plug and
then boom balanced budget you try that
with your taxes and see how that works
out for you oh they throw you in jail
but there's evidence that the money is
not being wasted it's actually part of
the pentagon's black budget in 1995 at
the preparedness Expo Phil Schneider
blew the whistle on one of the most
secret black budget programs in history
on the Southwest part of the Archuleta
Mesa we built an underground facility a
better part of three cubic miles
hollowed out on the ground we were in
the process of the early stages of
building we drill four large uh tunnel
like holes that some of them ran two and
a half miles under the surface
the equipment kept coming up broken so
we wanted to go down it wasn't send
somebody down there a human Observer or
human observers in this case
find out what was going on in 1979
Schneider was working for Morrison
Knutson on a geology team digging
exploratory shafts for a new underground
base in Dulce and the working with heavy
duty equipment the drills kept breaking
once the drill punched through Phil
described black Air billing up
through the opening and the air smelled
like rotten garbage Phil put on a
protective suit and headed down the lift
to investigate and on the way walking
through Camp he noticed there were an
awful lot of armed troops
what I saw Green Beret and Black Beret
people encamped inside of our geologist
Camp I knew something was up when Phil
reached the bottom he was face to face
with a seven foot tall gray alien he
said its stench was worse than anything
he'd ever smelled before then another
alien appeared Phil panicked grabbed his
pistol and started firing and he managed
to kill one of the aliens but the others
started firing back Phil was hit with
what he called a plasma weapon and lost
two fingers and part of his left hand
and this plasma weapon also gave him
cancer he never bring a gun to a plasma
fight that's good advice now Phil
thought he was dead when suddenly a
Green Beret who had followed him down
grabbed him and put him on the lift now
Phil made it but nobody else did 66 men
lost their lives in what was called the
Battle of Dulce base the American
Military had accidentally drilled into
an alien base that had been there for
four or five hundred years so now the
military had a choice to make go to war
with the aliens or cooperate with them
now winning a war against entities with
such advanced technology wasn't possible
so a deal was struck aliens would give
advanced technology to humans you know
what if the humans have to get to the
aliens well humans would have to give
the aliens other humans
did not tell us anything about the alien
threat
there's a war underneath there and I'm
talking dead serious Phil Schneider was
an outspoken advocate for government
transparency about the alien presence on
Earth he became well known on the UFO
lecture circuit giving talks about his
time working on top secret government
projects he's most known for his talk at
the 1995 preparedness Expo where he
revealed all kinds of information as of
1995 there were 131 active secret
underground bases in the United States
and
1477 around the world all the bases in
the United States are connected by
magnetic levitation trains that can
reach speeds of Mach 2. Phil said that
there are seven benevolent alien species
currently living on Earth and four evil
species he said that the US government
signed four treaties with the aliens in
1944 in 1954 1962 and the last one in
1979 after the Dolce battle the treaty
signed in 1954 called the griata treaty
was signed between the U.S Gulf
government and a species of great aliens
the treaty says aliens would be allowed
to abduct and experiment on humans as
long as the US government specifically
the committee known as Majestic 12 was
informed and provided a list of
abductees the government sure does like
making lists of people huh it sure does
why it is so many abductions don't
aliens know how boring humans are well
according to Phil Schneider at least
nine races of aliens view humans as a
food source it's a cookbook it's a
cookbook
[Music]
classic Twilight Zone episode but the
aliens don't consume human flesh instead
they use the secretions of glands for
mammals the species of aliens suffers
from a genetic disorder and the enzymes
in mammal hormones keep the aliens
healthy and some alien races use human
adrenaline as a recreational intoxicant
they get high from Human secretions they
do they yeah that's a hard pass for me
me too in exchange for access to humans
for experimentation the aliens would
provide the United States with advanced
technology according to Phil Schneider
military technology is 1200 years ahead
of what civilians have now stealth
technology came from Aliens the US
government now has the ability to create
special metal alloys but they can only
be created in the vacuum of space the US
military has a device that causes
earthquakes the 1989 San Francisco
earthquake and the 1995 Kobe earthquake
were weapons tests
and he fails to get Dave Parker at
second base so the Oakland A's takes
[Applause]
and Phil Schneider makes all kinds of
other claims he said the bombings of the
World Trade Center in 1993 and the
Oklahoma City bombing of 1995 were done
with miniature nuclear devices provided
by the aliens he said AIDS and other
viruses were created as a means of
controlling the population all right
hold on I gotta stop you there what
didn't mean to believe that a government
would artificially create a dangerous
virus in a lab my friend that is a
bridge too far sarcasm of course it's
sarcasm
Phil Schneider believed that all this
was happening for one purpose to
establish a new world order the alien
plan is to completely take over the
planet and eliminate almost 90 percent
of the world's population oh this is the
kind of talk that makes the Men in Black
come and knocking that's true and Phil
Schneider said he was under constant
surveillance by the government he even
claimed he was attacked by an FBI agent
and killed the agent in self-defense and
he reported this to the FBI but nothing
came of it not because the government
would have to admit to all this stuff
that's right pill was constantly in fear
for his life he said he had 11 close
friends all die under mysterious
circumstances but every death was ruled
suicide in fact Phil Schneider told his
friends and family over and over if I
ever end up dead I didn't kill myself it
was murder he was adamant about this oh
yeah I can't help notice that you keep
speaking about this guy in the past
tense well in January 1996 just four
months after he gave his famous lecture
Phil Schneider was found dead in his
apartment come on apparently he had
taken his own life
when I fly back to Arena excuse me to
Vegas I have to drive home
and I left my car down the face I'd
drive home alone I'm scared to help Phil
Schneider was constantly worried he told
his family that if he was ever found
dead to not believe the story that it
was murder a few weeks after that Phil
Schneider was found dead in his
apartment at first his death was ruled
unknown even though he had a medical
tube wrapped around his neck and a lot
of details about his death don't add up
first there was no note also he had
enough pills on hand to die painlessly
he also had a gun the medical tube was
wrapped around his throat three times
and then tied in a knot under his chin
now strangling yourself This Way seems
difficult especially in Phil's case he
was missing half of his left hand his
shoulders had limited motion he had
brittle bone Syndrome from cancer and
spent a lot of time in a wheelchair he
was a weak and frail man the medical
examiner for some reason refused to
visit the scene though he was legally
required to he did take blood and urine
samples but refused to test them because
he said it was a waste of time and when
Phil's family inquired about those
samples they were told they were sent to
an independent lab and were now missing
when Phil's ex-wife Cynthia went to
collect his belongings everything was
gone recordings of Phil's lectures
photographs research even physical
evidence from Dulce base it was all
missing then something very strange
happened an obituary appeared in the
local paper saying Phil died of a stroke
Phil's family didn't write that obituary
so who did
[Music]
any centered or House of Representative
person president United States Vice
President any any Cabinet member
flying
to the American public is a traitor and
should be dealt with in an appropriate
fashion
Phil Schneider wasn't the only person
who claimed to know about Dulce base
Thomas Castello was a military
photographer with top secret clearance
and he specialized in photographing
sensitive projects Castello worked at an
underground facility near Nellis Air
Force Base in Nevada most likely area
51. he also worked at Dulce base in 1987
Castello turned whistleblower and before
he left they'll say base he stole a set
of documents that were eventually called
the Dulce papers he also stole 30 black
and white photos as well as videotape
there are several things you should know
about I took an oath under penalty of
death that no matter what I saw or heard
I would never divulge the information at
the Dulce base treason is anything that
mentions the details of daily operations
at this facility when outside the
confinement of this base when I first
arrived the story they told us was that
this is a tri-biotransfer facility with
advanced technology doing Advanced
adventurous methodology for medical and
mental gains which is a fancy way of
saying they do really risky things with
human life just to see what would happen
this is the most famous Castello
photograph humans in pods
what the hell's going on here but you
know how aliens Harvest human hormones
for various purposes I'm trying to
forget it but yeah well these are
cloning bats much easier to use humans
as a food source when you could just
grow them in a tube and Castello was the
first person to show us the different
floors of Dulce base and what they were
used for level one is security and
Communications level two is human staff
and housing wait a minute if there's a
flaw labeled human staff then that means
there is housing for non-human staff no
level three is Executive offices and
Labs level four is mind control
experiments level five is alien housing
level six is genetic experiments and the
zoo
oh yeah when genetic splicing between
humans and Aliens was successful they
would often put the hybrid creature on
display Yeah Boy And level seven is
cryogenics and Cold Storage
um yeah this uh this story this is a lot
oh have you had too much oh wait there's
more oh much more
[Music]
the alien agenda is the complete
takeover of this planet the killing off
of five six two seven eights of the
world's population
by the year 2029
US military has known about this for 45
years they've told no one most of the
information we get from Castello comes
from a single interview he gave called
the Bratton interview and I'll link the
full text below apparently there were or
are over a hundred and eighty thousand
aliens working in the facility Costello
gives us details about how the bases
administered and there are many
different races that work there and
they're divided into ruling casts and
worker casts but obviously humans are
workers obviously but there are also
alien worker casts and ultimately all
Races report to a single ruling class
called the Draco
sounds like lizard people
Lizzy hey speaking of lizard people now
is a great time to
build what are you doing
someone's got to do the plugs go to shop
at the yfiles.com and grab your lizard
people mug today
anyway the Draco people
the lizard people are not alien they
evolved from reptiles and dinosaurs and
have remained hidden they created the
underground tunnel system hundreds or
thousands of years ago in the 1960s they
were made to be more suitable to humans
and other races that the Draco created
Created oh yeah the Draco created races
for labor the worker cast does the daily
chores mopping away Texas the worst
cleaning the cages bringing food to the
hungry people and other species it is
their job to formulate the proper
mixture for the type 1 and type 2 beings
that the Draco race has created the
working cast work at the lads as well as
at the computer Banks basically speaking
The Reptilian races are active at all
levels on the Dulce base there are
several different races of aliens of
work on the East section of level six
Thomas Castello lived the rest of his
life in hiding in Europe he since passed
away but if you're interested in hearing
more from him I'll post a link to a
message board where he answers a lot
more questions and I just scratched the
surface here his interview who is the
rabbitest of rabbit holes rabbitest shut
up hi they
unlier might have had a more interesting
life than his father William Lear who
invented the Lear jet John Lear was a
pilot who broke 17 World Records in many
types of aircraft he flew cargo planes
for the CIA in the 60s and 70s John Lear
was also one of the most visible
proponents of the theory that not only
are aliens here on Earth but they're
also colluding with the United States
government Lear became interested in
UFOs in 1986 after talking with U.S Air
Force personnel who witnessed the UFO
landing at bentwater's Air Force base
near London in that encounter three
small aliens walked right up to Wing
Commander General Gordon Williams and
that became known as the rendelsham
forest incident in 1988 Lear released a
document titled UFO cover-up that
exposed all kinds of secret government
and alien activity it's essentially a
Manifesto and a link to the original
text below Lear covers the death of
James Forrestal Majestic 12 Roswell
abductions cattle mutilations and of
course Dulce base Lear said that he
gathered four independent confirmations
that the seven-story dulce-based complex
was real even detailed the different
species of aliens who live and work
there it's in the master the problem is
not only just the fact that there are
five to five and as many as ten
different civilizations visiting us
apparently and this is from the research
that I've done at least 90 percent of
them are hostile and when I say hostile
uh if not hostile they have a completely
different set of morals than uh than we
do John Lear believed that based on
evidence aliens are trying to regenerate
their own race at our expense he said
they suffered a nuclear Holocaust or
severe illness that caused their entire
race to weaken this is why according to
John Lear aliens are attempting to cross
breed with humans in fact he said this
was successfully done seven times over
several years Lear discusses the book
Intruders by Bud Hopkins Hopkins spent
years studying abduction cases and was
one of the first to reveal that human
females were being used to gestate alien
or alien human hybrid children this was
information Hopkins learned through
interviewing and hypnotizing hundreds of
abductees now obviously John Lear didn't
subscribe to the theory that aliens are
here to protect us from nuclear war or
help us in any way aliens are here to
use us as livestock as breeding Chambers
and as subjects of horrible experiments
and what's even more frightening is the
United States government is complicit in
all of this John Lear ended his document
by saying the best advice I can give you
is next time you see a flying saucer and
are awed by its obvious display of
Technology run like hell
[Music]
in 1947 the air technical Intelligence
Center at Dayton is the top Air Force
intelligence Men And scientists under
contract sent a secret document to the
Commanding General of the Air Force
saying that whatever these things were
they were real and it started out with a
crash at Roswell
1947 is what the public has been told
uh something crashed in the backyard in
New Mexico a place called Roswell New
Mexico
unfortunately that's what the Public's
been told the military's known about the
alien question
for the better part of 70 years and a
second crash site that occurred uh in
Magdalena or Horse Mesa out west of
Magdalena New Mexico and I have found
out that the government has retrieved
between 10 and 15 factual flying saucers
three of which have been in perfect
condition one of which they tried to fly
and I know that they reverse engineering
I was never actually briefed on it but
you know Common Sense can tell me that
this craft over here isn't something we
made it was reverse engineered
reimbursement they trained nine months
before they ever flew it and then they
trained another I can't remember how
long four or five months flying all
around Nevada
and it worked fine I'm not attacking the
United States Air Force I'm attacking a
small group in there
that has been persistently keeping this
from the from the public just as they've
kept other things the Air Force has made
an art form of ridiculing people who
have talked about this thing they've
done an excellent job of covering it up
for the last 40 years we've been lied to
and the lies have got to stop and they
must stop immediately
well that was a roller coaster of a
story and not much of a happy ending but
what's true obviously there's no hard
evidence that they'll say base exists
but there's also no evidence that it
doesn't and since all we have are
eyewitness accounts let's look at the
witnesses first Phil Schneider this
isn't a Bob Lazar situation where all
the evidence is mysteriously erased
there are plenty of records that show
Phil did indeed work as a government
contractor on many different projects
but his story has some holes like his
misunderstanding of military and law
enforcement protocols procedures and
jurisdictions he said during the Battle
of Dulce there were 66 soldiers from the
U.S and NATO Green Berets black Berets
Delta Force and Secret Service the
Special Forces he names are American not
NATO NATO doesn't operate on American
soil and never has and even if it did
there's no way the US government would
allow foreign military to be present for
this kind of operation he said Delta
Force was there in 1979 Delta Force was
barely 18 months old very few people
even knew about it the military denied
its existence for years and even now
everything about Delta is classified we
don't know the size of the unit their
budget or their missions but we do know
that Delta Force was created as a
counter-terrorism unit I wouldn't expect
them to be on a domestic operation that
was essentially providing facility
security I could be wrong now in 1979
black Berets were only worn by Army
Rangers now could they have been
deployed for security sure but I doubt
it now Phil says the Secret Service was
there they weren't the Secret Service is
a law enforcement agency that
investigates crimes yes they provide
personal protection to high-ranking
political officials but that's a small
part of what they do Phil said he lost
his hand in the battle with aliens maybe
but his roommate from college said he
lost it when he was a young man working
as an electrical lineman putting up
power lines now Phil Schneider said his
father Oscar Schneider was a Nazi U-Boat
Captain who was captured and then fought
for the Americans in World War II Phil's
father was actually born in San
Francisco in 1906. till his grandparents
were born here too in Portland we have
documentation that Oscar Schneider was
in the United States until 1930 and then
he was in the U.S Navy medical Corps
from 1931 to 1946 and retired with the
rank of Captain he never commanded
submarines for Hitler or for the United
States he was a medical doctor who
specialized in shipboard safety
techniques now Phil shows this picture
in his lectures
have a picture of one of the aliens been
working for
the United States Pentagon for the last
58 years his name is Val Valiant Thor
he's right here if you remember our
video on Valiant 4 you know that Val was
most likely a fictional character
created by Frank strangest for his book
Stranger at the Pentagon which was a
ripoff of The Day the Earth Stood Still
the photo Phil uses is supposedly his
father in The Ready room of the USS
Eldridge because his father was part of
the Philadelphia Experiment because of
course he was but there's no room that
large on a Canon class destroyer also
the Philadelphia Experiment happened in
the 40s the lights in this picture
wouldn't be used until the 1960s and
there are lots more holes in the story
and Phil Schneider had a documented
history of mental illness his story
sounds like paranoid delusions he says
28 percent of the US GDP is used for
Black Ops 28 is very specific why not 25
or over 30. how does he even know that
number the people who work in Black Ops
don't know the pentagon's budget nobody
does but somehow Phil knows people with
delusions often create Rich worlds full
of specific details now Phil Schneider
very well could have been telling the
truth I just don't think so I think he
suffered a psychotic break in dealing
with his cancer diagnosis and latched
onto the dulce-based story as a way to
take control of his life and as a way to
attain some notoriety that all said his
death
was weird
[Music]
if you trace back the history of the
Dulce base story you'll always end up
with a person named James Bishop whose
real name was allegedly Tao Levesque now
the book saucers Spooks and Kooks UFO
disinformation in the age of Aquarius
written by Adam go rightly identifies
Levesque as the Chief Architect of the
Dulce base story in the 70s Levesque
published a newsletter called Hollow
Earth hassle which was about creatures
living inside the earth and those
stories were based on a story called The
shaver mystery which appeared in science
fiction pulp magazines in 1947 and the
story took off after Paul benowitz
claimed he discovered alien
Transmissions coming from Dulce base a
woman named Anne West created the Tom
Costello character probably based
somewhat on what Paul benowitz said that
she claimed that a lot of her
information was coming from someone
named Tom Costello but all the
information was coming from Levesque and
you won't be surprised to hear that no
record of anyone named Thomas Castello
was found in the U.S military during the
time he was supposed to be there
according to Levesque various
researchers would latch onto the
dulce-based story and then add their own
Flair each person building on the story
of the people who came before them and
by the way that super creepy photo of
the humans and alien pots Thomas
Castello didn't take that picture it's
actually a screenshot of the film The
Sixth Day released in 2000.
now why would Levesque do this well he
passed away in 2018 but he said it was
his job whatever that means we know for
a fact that agent Richard Doty of the
Air Force OSI perpetrated a
misinformation campaign against Paul
benowitz and this campaign included
conferring Paul's suspicion about the
underground base and confirming the
drawings by abductee Myrna Hansen now
was Levesque part of this government
operation we don't know John Lear also
circulated this story and at one UFO
convention Lear met with other UFO
researchers who were going to release a
public statement about what they knew to
be true apparently lear's claims were so
outlandish the other researchers
wouldn't sign on to it Lear stormed out
of the convention you have to get pretty
wild when people at a UFO convention
don't believe you you sure do Bill Moore
a UFO researcher who worked with Richard
Doty and the government on the
misinformation campaign he said Lear was
an intelligence agent now remember Lear
did have a long history of working with
the CIA okay now this is the problem
with these stories UFOs underground
bases alien experiments as long as the
research is considered Fringe most of
the people working in the field are
going to be Fringe they don't give out
Nobel prizes for UFO research they
should they should and maybe one day
they will but until then UFO researchers
will be criticized and ostracized by
mainstream scientists now me and you
want to believe but there's nobody to
trust we know for a fact that Richard
Doty ran a misinformation campaign
against benowitz and the entire UFO
Community feeding them wild stories
about aliens and underground bases but
later Dodie said the stories were mostly
true so now we're left in this position
where we don't know who or what to
believe we do know that the US
government wants it this way now I
believe there are secret bases all over
the United States is there one in Dulce
I don't know there are lots of UFO
stories that I want to be true but this
isn't one of them abductions genetic
experiments organ harvesting and a new
world order we better hope Phil
Schneider John Lear Myrna Hansen and all
these other Witnesses are wrong because
if they're not we're in big trouble
today's episode is brought to you by one
of the most unique sponsors we've ever
had established titles and that doesn't
sound like VPN software it's not huh
nice change of pace established titles
let you buy as little as one square foot
of land in Scotland and this allows you
to call yourself Lord or Laird as they
say or lady also established titles
plants a tree with every order and is
partnered with great Charities like one
tree planted
hold on what did you just say I could
buy land in Scotland and become a lord
yep you can even use the title on your
credit cards plane tickets online dating
profile yep so I want it well there's
more I want to tell you about this I
want it now Lord Heckle fish
fine
[Music]
and it's my Lord package
I hear it
you're kidding me right
what is this um what is this my Lord if
you don't mind well you might be taking
this a little bit
okay okay hang on I could
okay
this certifies you as Lord hecklefish
Moriarty and uh this is the plot Number
of your land in Edelson Scotland and uh
they even sent us coordinates Google Map
it that I may survey my domain
oh this is pretty nice it is I can't
wait to get some surfs out there to work
the land for me and pay me tribute uh
you can't have any serves I shall be a
strict but fair Lord of these lands
myself will come to idolize me you can't
have serfs I can maybe have a few safes
you can't one surf no stop saying surfs
stop saying surfs my Lord all right but
check this out the first 200 people who
purchase a title pack using the promo
code twf will get land right near yours
Kingdom Kinda Yeah I shall be a strict
but fair Lord to all who purchase using
promo code twf well you won't be there
Lord they'll be Lords and Ladies of
their own land not for now but when I
raise an Army in crocodile land I shall
rule over them and they will come to
know me as a strict but fair Lord you
can't conquer their land there may be a
marriage pact to strengthen the kingdom
I don't see how that Shelby truth my
eldest son to the daughter of one of the
other Lords we will unite our kingdoms
and my blood shall rule these lands for
a thousand years you have an eldest son
what do you think those guppy support
payments are for Heckle Jr lives with
his mother in Hackensack New Jersey if
you use code twf you'll get an
additional 10 off so go to
establishtitles.com twf you'll be Lord
of your own land you'll get your own
plot number and you get this cool frame
certificate this makes an amazing last
minute gift plus you'll be supporting a
great charity and helping out the
channel and you'll be joining my kingdom
right and that you will come to know me
as a strict
yeah we got it feel before me get bent
it don't make me declare priminata ugh
gross
[Laughter]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's Heckle
fish this has been the y-files and if
you had fun or learned anything do us a
favor like subscribe comment share I
know I'm a broken record but that stuff
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover here today's topic was
recommended by you by lots of you
actually and if there's something that
you want to hear or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips and special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible we couldn't do it
without you if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon or grab something from the white
file store have I mentioned the lizard
people mug you have it makes a great
last minute gift and if you use the code
lizard people one word you get 10 off
your entire order that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]